nearby knife
rubber toes first bling Empire star Anna
Shea has died she was 62 years old and
his family confirmed to ET on Monday
that she died of a stroke and the past
can be the past but my mother used to
say if you don't find closure in that
page in that chapter in the book then
you can't turn to the next page
Kim Lee tells E.T Anna gave me so many
words of wisdom I will never forget and
on Instagram Dorothy Wang Praises Anna's
generosity boldness and fervor with
Kelly me Lee sharing this message for
her late co-star you are truly one of a
kind and we will miss you forever don't
miss me one thing yeah you don't let the
clothes wear you Anna was seen as a
matriarch of the cast across the show's
three seasons you don't let the
skateboard ski you you don't let the car
drive you
don't be impressed by things I don't get
impressed by things about people and who
they are in a statement Anna's loved
ones remember how she taught them not to
take life too seriously and to enjoy the
Finer Things oh my God this is the
smallest horse in the world it's like a
baby and a mommy it's just too huge Anna
is survived by her son Kenny I think
it's very important to have fun in the
last 10 years I kind of slowed down on
it I wanted to spend my time with my son
and my family but
then I realized that it was time for me
to do things for myself again